have you ever wondered what the world's
longest ongoing war is I've been
fascinated with this border for a very
long time and a few months ago I went to
just go see what it looked like and I
found something kind of insane so one of
the major ways that North and South
Korea fight each other today is with
speakers there is an ongoing battle
between North and South Korea on who can
blast the loudest propaganda or music at
each other South Koreans Will Blast like
K-pop and all sorts of things sometimes
they'll just like make fun of North
Koreans on a hot day for not having like
movie theaters they can go into with air
conditioning North Korea on the other
hand will just blast like communist
propaganda like these operas from the
Soviet times and then we'll get so loud
like to the point where it will become
like damaging like in like we'll break
glass so they've actually had to like
like come to some agreement to come to
the table and be like no more speaker
Wars